y van a ser buenas tardes
tenemos los testimonios de varios de los
ex presos que han estado recluidos en un
contango durante estos 20 años y también
hace unos años uno de los comités del
senado de eeuu en un informe por
desgracia todavía no ha publicado en su
supo que totalmente han revelado muchas
de estas alegaciones de tortura que por
desgracia no se han investigado de
manera plena pero sí que hay muchas
alegaciones y muchos indicios de que los
diferentes detenidos han sufrido
diferentes tipos de tortura entre ellos
también desapariciones forzadas es decir
no podían comunicarse con sus familias
no podían comunicarse con abogados y ni
siquiera podían decir dónde estaba y
cuando joe biden era vicepresidente de
eeuu en el 2009 el prometió que iba a
cerrar guantánamo que ha hecho al
respecto ahora que es el presidente de
eeuu
si este es un tema que llevamos muchos
años luchando para conseguir que por fin
se cierre el centro de detención de
guantánamo y es verdad que el presidente
obama prometió que cerraría la base de
intención y yo byron porque pertenecía a
ese equipo que había tomado esa decisión
desde que bailén está en el gobierno y
lamentamos que solo un detenido
ha sido liberado y además no han
recuperado una figura que tuvieron
durante la época de obama era una
persona encargada especialmente de
llevar a cabo el proceso de cierre de la
base de detención 'tendremos que es una
posición complicada todavía quedan 39
personas allí dentro y requiere de
alguien que se encargue de liderar todo
este proceso porque requiere que esta
gente pueda salir de allí por fin
algunos de ellos recordemos que llevan
más de una década que el gobierno de
eeuu ha dicho que pueden marcharse pero
que todavía no han encontrado dónde
pueden ir o no está arreglado toda la
situación y por tanto si ya tienen gente
que han dicho que se pueden marchar de
allí y no han conseguido sacarlos
claramente necesita de un liderazgo
importante que ahora mismo el gobierno
de bagdad nos está poniendo y esto es lo
que una de las cosas que les reclamamos
y como se menciona todavía quedan y
nueve presos en guantánamo brevemente en
qué condición están ellos
sí pues es complicado saber exactamente
cómo están porque el acceso es difícil
incluso para sus propios abogados no
siempre es sencillo y muchos de ellos
están a la espera de un juicio que es
entre comisión militar por tanto no
cumple con las garantías mínimas del
juicio puesto que incluso algunos de
ellos en catorce de ellos
van a quedar encinta de manera
indefinida y no sabemos nada de cuál va
a ser su futuro más allá que el gobierno
ha decidido que van a estar recluidos la
información que tenemos es poca pero
sabemos que en sus condiciones no sólo
como deberían ser entre otras cosas
porque no están recibiendo las garantías
de un recluso de una prisión está
estándar